the clark county school district posts a
controversial proposal about redefining
employee free speech
it went up in the district website
before the holiday weekend and was
removed about an hour ago
kristen drummond shows us the concerns
among ccsd staff
and its legality we all should be
standing up
uncertainty and unease this is like the
worst
possible time for them to roll out
something like this
ccsd staff and parents questioned the
intention of a policy proposal removed
suddenly monday evening from the
district website
a two-page document titled employee
freedom of speech
these are screenshots of the regulation
that seems to impose restrictions on
when employees can talk freely about
public concerns
which includes district issues what was
the origin
of proposing a regulation like this we
believe that this
is someone in the district's attempt
to keep employees from
speaking up about important issues
troubling many ccsd staff
as well as free speech attorney ari
cones it's
a policy that you can barely read four
sentences without hitting something that
it gets wrong
he found the document and posted a
twitter thread calling it a really bad
policy drafting
i think the thing that struck me is that
it
seemed to quote language that sounded
familiar
from the supreme court cases but the way
it did it
made you really wonder if the people
actually read the cases
the education support employees
association released a statement
it says in part the trustees should
withdraw this embarrassing
and unconstitutional proposal or they
will waste district dollars having a
court do it for them
the clark county education association
tells me the union has nothing to share
at this time kristin drummond 8 news now
the aclu continues to analyze the
document or waiting to hear back from
the speech experts at the national
office